everybody we're going to get started
momentarily
and you could say hi in the chat
which i have on the screen here
i'll be the first to say hi
okay i guess i wasn't hello
ali and like i mentioned in case
you're just filtering in we're gonna get
started here in a minute or two
hello quincy founder of
free code camp
emery hello
muhammad abeau deep i i'm just
i'm terrible at these names
all right here they come
craig mullins with a verified check mark
hello everybody
hello hello hello all right
so while everybody's getting filtered in
um i will go ahead and start the
introduction first i'm gary simon i've
been a ui
ux designer and front-end developer for
the last 20-plus years i've been an
instructor
in teaching for the last 10 years and
this is the third of the three streams
that we've had scheduled uh for myself
to stream a live ui ux review show
here at free code camp on the youtube
channel so perhaps we'll do this again
sometime in the future
but basically what we're doing is you
are submitting your ui
designs and i'm reviewing them
live here all right so i already have a
few picked out but you do that
on twitter and you just use the hashtag
live ui ux review and i may get you to
yours
i may not but still there's value even
if
i don't get to yours because a lot of
people make the same mistakes
and we can all learn from each other of
course um and so this is uh just a real
quick plug
uh designcourse.com i'm going to be
we're actively working on this and it's
going to be the most comprehensive
that's my goal at least the most
comprehensive uh service for learning ui
ux design um so that's coming in several
months time if you want to be notified
when that's i
released go ahead and enter your email
here at designcourse.com
and then secondly my youtube channel i
right here it's design course it's
linked here in the youtube description
of this video
um so yeah let's go ahead and
get started so here's one that i chose
this is a levi landing page with gsap
all right so if you people don't know
what gsap
is gsap is an acronym for the green sock
animation platform
it allows you to do uh more complex
animations uh rather than just using
something like straight up css
animations um so notice how everything
comes in sequentially
gsap makes this very easy to do in the
front end development process it's
javascript library
it's very powerful i have several
courses on it on my own
youtube channel so you can definitely
check that out to learn how to do this
sort of thing
so this is a a nice design overall
a there's nothing i can't scroll a lot
of this doesn't work so kind of what you
see is what you get here
um and in terms of the ui design itself
i really like it um it's
it's unique it's interesting um i don't
think see anything that really is coming
out as being
uh negative with this one um it's using
some
modern ui design techniques like uh
having kind of like this
vertical bar over here um
the whole circular navigation up here
assuming this were ever to be finished
so yeah
i i like it i can't really say anything
negative for what it is
so also as a part of these live streams
i do
um i ask everybody watching here in the
youtube chat
to give it a rating one being the worst
and 10 being the best you have about 15
seconds and then we'll see
if i agree with you or not so go ahead
and do that
one being the worst 10 being the best
consider the ui design
any ux potential issues you see and
factor that
into your result
somebody's already given it a 10. no he
said eight
well let's see if this is responsive
first of all we could check that out
no not quite just kind of made it for
desktop
always learn css first and then try to
use gsap for your animation purposes
okay i'm going to go ahead i'm going to
give this one for what it is
a straight up
8.1 yeah there we go
all right i think it's pretty solid okay
next one i have picked out
all right so sort of a cool loading
animation we saw here let's refresh that
very cool um the thing that i notice
right off the bat that is an issue is
the lack of white space or the too much
white space here so this isn't
necessarily a white space issue it's an
alignment issue
this block right here which is comprised
of this headline
this sub headline and this call to
action should all be
pushed down considerably so when i say
that
we're going to give this like a margin
top
of i don't know
5 m units there we go so now we have
almost an equal amount of white space
from the top and bottom and now it looks
in
it's it's quite a bit better i would
also probably make this right here
a little bit less width um maybe put in
on the next line right here
that way it gives it a little bit more
white space between this element and
this element
i really like the uh illustration here
it being animated like this uh so this
makes sense has like you little
skeleton ui windows so it's always a
good idea to use illustrations that are
relevant based on the purpose of the
landing page
and the surface itself um
let's okay up here we have a light and
dark mode
i kind of don't like this one because
you're not sure which one is
cho is really chosen yeah this is light
version obviously but it should be a
little bit more obvious like this should
be
filled in here perhaps already by
default and
sometimes to me i wasn't even sure what
this was
at a glance i thought it was like a
chocolate chip cookie
but just the moon but look checking this
out anyhow
this is pretty good um just for how
everything
reacts when you're switching from light
to dark
all right coming down one thing i do
want to say is
this this section right here this
container because it's a very
very subtle difference from this white
to this very light desaturated sort of
blue
i think it's not enough contrast i think
we needed to just maybe
a little bit make that a tad bit darker
so
you can see it's almost white up here in
the color picker so if we come down
just a little bit i think that's better
so now we can clearly see the separation
of these two
you know this this section up here which
is traditionally called the hero section
and then this section right here
so i would say the same thing about this
section over here same color you'd want
to change it to
up here so you have a more of a
distinction between these containers
so if i refresh it you'll see the
original and it just kind of makes it a
little bit harder to see the card
and this section being separated itself
this i really like this section right
here um everything is is i
aligned correctly there's a good white
space
the topography is good there's a good
visual hierarchy which is reinforced by
the fact that you know your different
pieces of
type are um changed
and they're separated with each other to
create that hierarchy
through uh the font weight through the
font size
and contrast between these elements
so those three things will really give
you good typography if you
understand how to apply them so and this
is all pretty solid i like the icons
they're simple
this here again you could probably
on it on a large viewport like this put
in
three or four of these um
in a uh different columns so three
instead of just having two because that
really makes them really large
i'd probably put at least three when
you're out here
in the larger viewports
but other than that this is all solid i
like the the type inside
we're using labels on your forum that's
excellent
you should always have a contact form on
your site don't just put your email
address like a mail to link or something
i always have a form that people can
contact you with
but i would also say always give them a
way to email that you
if they wish instead of using your form
so offer both
you want to give them as many ways to
contact you as possible this is solid
though
so i what do you think this person
should get for a rating for
their portfolio one being the worst
timing the best i think the biggest
issue was just this
area right here too much white space get
that centered here vertically
oh we got a super chat
thank you for that which goes to free
code camp
one being the worst 10 me and the best
get your
answers in
is another high higher rated entry
for sure so for me
i'm going to go ahead and give this one
and 8.3
or so i i noticed so there's a lot of
eights there's a lot of nines there's
some sevens
so yeah pretty pretty solid
quincy says seven he wasn't as impressed
okay
all right next up is going to be an
adobe xd
prototype
all right so what we have here is
digital marketing
agency um there's several areas that we
can click
one thing just about the topography i
like the colors
this seems to be a good font size this
is the mott cigarette
type uh font family which i know because
i use forever and i still use
um i think a little bit more line height
it's a little bit scrunched up in my
opinion
um so i would increase the line height
just a bit
um outside of that pretty
solid uh call to action here so adobe xd
has the ability to animate on hover
um i'm not sure
if i would increase the size of these
honestly on hover
but uh nonetheless your alignment's good
you notice you're in the the very first
link the home nav
uh defines a column here and then right
along this column
is the rest of this content and that
that creates a nice
uniform consistent layout it just makes
it look better
um one thing i don't like is that meet
our team button
the the gray the mid gray right here
it's very hard to to use mid gray
effectively in the ui design
um in this button here being blue it
doesn't contrast very well so i would
change this color
to to something else you could either go
light
i probably wouldn't make it this blue
color because then it competes
uh for your your primary call to action
so i would use maybe a really dark maybe
very
you know almost as dark as this for the
background here
next up looking at this area this area
it's designed well like the cards has
good white space inside
however it's a little bit confusing um
because you've chosen to emphasize a few
over the others and i'm not sure if
that's
necessarily what you wanted to do um so
sometimes also i don't know what these
little dots are for
it almost makes me think like there
might be some sort of weird inner
navigation within this
this card so it's kind of confusing um
but i would probably opt just to style
them all the same
unless there's some type of reason that
you want to emphasize one or the other
over the other
next up this is this right here is
pretty solid
and this is kind of quite bordery or
lining if you will
you could probably either drop the
contrast significantly on the border you
know making it just a very dark gray
or you could get rid of the border
entirely and make the background of this
card
i just a little like a shade lighter
than the background
that way it won't feel like so many
lines it's fine here
because you really want to emphasize
this middle one but
it becomes a little bit cluttered in my
opinion with the extra borders
and always make sure you're using labels
so if you're these look like they would
be placeholder values
and you don't want to rely on those make
sure they're floating
good call to action here and yeah again
same comments about this
this mid gray all right what do you
think this person should get rated
one being the worst and 10 being the
best you have about 15 seconds to get
your answers
in
the font family for that one was monster
at
which you can download that that's
available google fonts
i've been hitting the gym hard so i'm
like i need to stretch
i'm like very sore right now
oh we got a lot of ratings that came in
all the way
all right so for me um based on what i
see here
it's it's overall this part's a little
bit cluttered and misaligned
um but overall it's pretty decent
there's no significant
issues here so i'm going to rate this
uh like a 6.9 maybe even a 7
or so i think that's pretty fair based
on
what i've rated the other
ones all right so let's do yet another
one
so we've been looking at some pretty
decent um entries up to this point so
far
this one needs some work though a little
bit more than the other ones
so why do i say that well
first of all the first issue that i
notice here is
alignment all right so
we have this logo right here in the logo
by the way
there's too much type in that logo i'm
not sure whoever created this if you
have
control over the logo which you might
not because you're a ui
or designer or you're a friend of
developer whatever
there's just i would have it refactored
there's just too much type occurring
here
outside of that though it creates a a
column here
and it in and also in and of itself if
we're just going to take a
look at the nav bar which is which is
the logo plus
this navigation right here navigation is
completely
fluid all the way to the right of the
browser and then this is just kind of
pushed over
like randomly if it's going to be really
fluid then this should be pushed over
all the way over here as well
to create that nice symmetry but
one thing so we have that issue but then
the next issue is
you have this column defined by
all the type right here so it's thrown
off
in a couple different ways the best way
to deal with this is to take this logo
put it right here and then also take
this
navigation and put it the contact us
should probably end
right here and so it would go like this
length
and then if you're kind of worried about
the navigation being a little bit too
close at that point to the logo because
it'll be moved here and this will be
moved in the middle
um you could expand the width of this
this
fixed container that's centered here at
this resolution
or this this eye viewport
all right after that
there's not a ton of contrast with this
red
and this background you can read it but
when you get to this
this area is pretty fine because it's
dark but when you get over here to this
table or whatever it is
it it there's not you can have more
contrast this could even possibly be
white
the way to fix that is multiple ways
changing the color of the type on top
like
making it completely white or further
taking this photograph and making it
darker
there's an issue also with your call to
actions
so we have three different buttons in
this area
call us send us a message in free
estimate that are all
designed in the same exact manner so
that's a lack of visual hierarchy the
free estimate button is probably going
to be the one that's most important and
the one that you want people to to click
on
so every every page should have a goal
of some sort
and this one clearly it would probably
be to
free us to get a free estimate also a
free estimate i'm not sure
what that entails verse call us i guess
this is just the phone number
and then send us a message so if you
want to have these buttons here
make style them differently it's so that
they don't catch as much
attention from the eye that this one
does this one should
this is what you want people to use so
style these differently
i wouldn't use red as a background for
these there's a lot of different ways
you can do it to have secondary call to
actions
and also this kind of seems just
misplaced i would place these maybe
underneath the free estimate or to the
right
of the free estimate button outside of
that
this part's pretty decent right here in
the middle
there's nothing really 100 wrong uh
happening
at basically for the most part
everywhere else
whenever you have two columns like this
here's the left column and here's the
right column
i prefer to not center text that's in
the right or left
maybe just left align these elements and
that way you really define this this
this uh column right here
outside of that that is it and it's uh
there's just a few small things that
could improve it what do you think this
person should get for a rating one being
the worst and 10 being the very best
quincy asked i've heard the right number
of call to actions is
always one are there exceptions to that
i think it depends on what
you may define as a call to action so um
if there should always be at least a
primary call to action
and if we're talking primary then by
nature we're talking one so yes you'd be
correct
in this case uh we we have a lot of
secondary
sort of call to actions if you will or
you know areas that people could
actually leave um
and in that case they should be not
styled as prominently as that primary
one if that makes sense
so for this one i'm going to go ahead
and give this i mean there's not a lot
of like
horrible things happening here so for me
i'm going to give this one
like a 6.2
or so
once he's uh says 5.5 i think he's just
a little bit
we're pretty much consistent in in our
ratings though it's a little bit lower
than what i'm writing
all right i
oh here we go
47 roof construction.com
all right so this this layout to me
it feels dated it's uh it's like back in
2013 2014 2015 these are the type of
like
layouts that i saw often um
it has the logo here and has like these
little areas where
you can have you know the access to to
call the people there's also
the address um we have a very standard
hero section with the centered area here
and my dog is barking down there
um having said that
i guess you could you can maybe take a
little bit of a point away
just because it's dated however the
things that we need to be
most certain of is that the ui
in the ux is working well so in that
case
i can't really say there's anything too
wrong sorry
my voice is cracking up about what i see
here
um request a complimentary inspection
today that's a good headline
get in touch i would probably bold up
the white because this green versus this
white text you lose a little bit of
contrast there
so i might use it maybe a slightly
darker green
or bold up and make it a little bit
larger this getting touch button
where does a get in touch button do um
is there a contact page
unfortunately it's kind of a slow
loading right now
and it's not secure maybe this isn't
live yet i'm not sure
one of one of the here's a tip if you
ever want to increase your leads
and this would be considered a lead if
somebody contacts you using this contact
form
i would and you only have a few or a
small amount of fields that you're
requesting
there's one of two things you could do
you could just take this feel free to
contact us page
and you could put this in a right column
and then left align this in the left
column
that way it's one less click that people
have to
to to to do in order to get in touch
with you
uh especially if you have a server that
this is being hosted on that's kind of
slow because that took
too much too long way too long to get to
that page
so you're gonna reduce your your bounce
rate you're going to increase your
amount of leads
um and the other way to approach it is
maybe just if you have more fields
then you're comfortable with putting you
know in your hero section of the landing
page then
maybe just put one or two and then it
will just take them to the next one
because they're already invested
uh in filling out all the the
information
outside of that about us maybe a little
bit more white space here
we are your insurance experts contact us
yeah i mean this is all
it's all pretty solid here i don't see
anything that's that's coming out and
just
being completely wrong with exception to
this area because they're only
placeholder values
we want to make this accessible so make
sure you use the labels as always
all right so one being the worst ten
being the best what do you think this
person should get for a rating
some people are saying five five three
i'm going to go ahead and say
let's see let's see if at least if it's
working responsively and it is
yeah so for me oh we agree this time
i'm going to say maybe around 6.5 to
like a 6.8
or maybe even close to a seven now that
i think about it
yeah so pretty solid here all right
um next up
this is like an english learning app of
some sort
um it's a yeah english leading course
center
all right um
by the way like if it's a template
there's no way for me to know if
it's a template or not um so i always
just make the assumption that
it's not a template um so okay
first thing i think is a little strange
is this this little settings cog
like what does that do theme color
oh interesting okay so they let you
choose the theme here
which on a landing page i'm not too
certain makes that much sense to be
honest with you
um random background right bullet i mean
it's cool to showcase that you can do
this and you know how but
i'm not sure if it makes sense on the
landing page um the biggest issue here
though
when i check this out is
the headline and the sub headline
they're just
really i they're they're boring in my
opinion um this needs to be enlarged a
lot
especially in this viewport you know
this right here
i'm not the size is 2m i mean you could
bump that up to like 6m
uh or 5m units and
that way it's already so much better so
look at this scale so this is an issue
of a ui design fundamental called scale
uh the size of things it doesn't
necessarily have to pertain
just to type it could be anything
but if i refresh this oh
not cool you know so beef that size up
considerably this is also lacking
a call to action um you know at the very
least
if you want to tell people to scroll
down go ahead and do that
these up here i wouldn't call these
really any
any sorts of a primary call to action so
same thing with this over here just kind
of gets lost sometimes it's
not immediately identifiable so you want
to give somebody
you know an area where you know they
need to click
and where they have to click that's up
to you
and that's a ux concern where is it that
you want them to land
first so just
this is quite a long about a section
i at the very least if you're going to
keep all this text
maybe use two different paragraphs
because it's kind of like a wall of text
so
peop people don't like reading that um
this is these cards you gotta scrap
those
um in what by i mean scrap i mean you
need to change up the design
uh the borders plus the thick
uh drop shadow makes it look amateur and
dated so i mean i'll guarantee you right
now i can fix these
up the box shadow get rid of that
so there we go we've already simplified
it much more
you add these back and it just looks
cheesy so you don't need that
um you could where's the border at um
trying to find the border
i'm not sure where the border property
is defined here oh there it is
if we get rid of that then we can use
this box
shadow but though it's still the box
shadow is still too strong
you want to take the opacity which is at
.76
um drop it down
a lot like
0.2 and then we could probably increase
um
the blur reverse spread
that's better that's a better take so
there's when it comes to design
ui design as well you know you have a
certain amount of subjectivity
uh or in other words personal
preferences um
so this is one way to take it but what
one way i would not take it
is this the original
i'm not sure why this is
you know really emphasized there
otherwise if you if you styled it
similarly to the rest it would look
a lot better it kind of looks out of
place and then this is a big issue here
these are broken
um the little uh circular
pagination buttons are overlapping
um but yeah what do you think this
person should get for a rating one being
the worst and 10 being the best
somebody asked why you should use a
label instead of a placeholder the
placeholder value
when you start typing in that text field
or the text area or whatever
it's it automatically clears it
and then some people may forget what
they're entering
um and so it becomes a an accessibility
issue
so always having it in plain view makes
sense
this this definitely is not a one no
i've seen
ones before and i've rated a few ones
this is this is this is higher than a
one
um but for me i'm gonna have to rate
this maybe a little bit lower than
normal let me see what it looks like
responsively
it is responsive so they're doing all
that correct
i'm going to go ahead and rate this one
a
about 5.8 or so 5.7
all right
all right um next
up i had just two more that i had you
know that i
checked out beforehand
this is there's a number of issues here
with this one
so scroll down
the biggest issue with this this right
here is a is a ux issue it's not even a
ui design issue um you're not addressing
and telling me what the purpose of the
site is about why
why do i have to scroll down why should
i scroll down
why would i want to scroll down people
are going to leave this site
quickly second i would say
having these two navigations like this
both encased in this high contrast white
area
or this container rather that doesn't
make sense
um you're if you're gonna do this the
navigation makes more sense to do that
than this secondary uh and i mean
secondary in terms of importance your
social navigation so
you know one way to fix that because
that creates an issue of visual
hierarchy is you can just take this
and the background is white so what we
can do
is we'll change that background
to just slightly lighter than
this and then you would want to take
these icons and make them all white
and also get rid of this weird box this
outer glow that you have
and then that way things are kind of
restored to normal
so scroll down whoa
i wasn't i wasn't expecting that
initially i did see this
before i started the stream but i didn't
scroll down so if i start scrolling down
things are really happening quickly oh
no
and if you're going to do this sort of
thing that better be a watermark in the
background because now you have visual
clutter all over the place
you're locking white space between these
sections you don't want to stretch your
images like that
it does not look good you want to work
on your type as well
this almost looks like a comic sans
i would get rid of this eye border
completely unnecessary
yeah we just have some issues here you
know quite a bit of issues with
topography
these should be styled a little bit more
differently from each other
this would be a great example of
somebody who could definitely
benefit from checking out like my ui
design courses i have
several that are free on my youtube
channel
also you can check out skrinba.com i
have a ui design bootcamp there
because you kind of need to really just
start from the beginning
um and really learn your ui design
fundamentals much more
all right so we're going to go ahead and
rate this one being the worst and 10
being the best
number of ui issues uh ux issues as well
so we got to factor those in this is a
big no-go
absolutely not nobody can read this you
don't want to have
vertical text and paragraphs of vertical
text you can get away with it if it's
just tiny amounts of
text i but when it comes to this
no no no no
i'm gonna have to give this one i'm
looking at the ratings coming in
yeah i'm gonna go ahead and give this
one
a
2.8 or so
yeah i think that makes sense
all right we have one more um that
i i checked out beforehand and then
we'll switch to twitter
wow quincy gave it a four and i gave it
a 2.8
all right all right so
here's one of those issues and one of
the dangers
of trends design trends
um being overused and maybe not being
used
correctly and that is at the start of
this year i did a video about it it was
really popular
about a new design trend called new
morphism
and you could see these buttons with
their real soft appearing and stuff and
people went crazy on twitter i mean on
dribble i
because it was really cool the person
did it in a really good context for a
user interface of an app
um but as we could see these it's been
applied here what knew more
new morphism is is we could see like
elements and containers
have this light uh shadow over here
done achieved through the box shadow
property and you can have multiple block
shadows
and then the second one is just like a a
darker shadow here
and they're real soft but when you do
this like on
almost every element it just makes it
look
just too amateur in my opinion because
it's very similar to your typical
shadows that you've seen that were your
drop shadows that we've seen for 20 plus
years
we have issues with alignment so we have
this column that's here but then we have
this slightly inset
so that's not working out i do like
the take though on
light and dark mode um
these could be okay so for your hot your
the hover of these
the contrast gets killed with this blue
color you're using based on
this mid-sorted gray color here and
another thing that kind of hurts it too
is using this mid gray color it kind of
just looks bland in my opinion
so you need to think about that it looks
like you're just taking people
straight into your portfolio examples
right here
but it probably would be it would make
sense at least to have a little section
at the top
that kind of describes what you are and
you know what you do
it does say front end web developer but
you could probably expand on that a
little bit more
um in sort of like a hero section it
doesn't have to be the 100
100 viewport height or whatever but just
a section up top
instead of just having people go
straight 100 into your your
projects
all right so what do you think this
person should get rated for
their portfolio one being the worst in
10 being
the best
let me go ahead and check and see how
long we've been streaming
all right
38 minutes ago okay
try to be constructive by the way
i mean if i showed you some of my first
designs
back in the late 90s yeah you would all
die
um i'm going to go ahead and give let's
see if the let's check responsiveness
it is responsive so for this
i'm going to go ahead and give it
something like around
a
i think a 4.5 or so would make sense
all right you know designing sites is
not easy it's definitely a skill that
has to be learned
um in fact let me do something real
quick
i'm going to take a a little bit of a
detour
and i'm going to go to my
youtube channel and i'm going to go to
my search my channel search i'm going to
type 1999.
here it is lol i found my old design
work from 1999 so this is going to make
a lot of you feel better
if you watch this video um
and this is when i put this out about
three years ago this video
and if i i'm going to scroll just to
show you some of my designs back
in like there are some that are from
1998
i think um and you're gonna see some of
my designs
like that was my portfolio look at that
this was i
when i was i created a lot of portfolios
like that's
almost all of my work comprised of was
like that's how i got practice by by
making a million portfolios um
designs like look at this my skills
flash
three four i have three years experience
html dhtml
java i never mess with java i don't know
why
i even put that maybe i meant javascript
mysql php
visual basic i was one of those horrible
people who
created aol apps or they were called
progs
back then or progs for like kicking
people offline and stuff like
punters and stuff but that's kind of how
i learned to code
um but yeah just looking through this
i'm looking
there's a lot i mean look at this now
you have to remember look at that you
have to remember that this was
this is actually i was really proud of
this one it was really unique back then
um this is one of my first portfolios
right here
hi my name is gary simon i'm 16 years
old and i live in warren ohio
i mean can you imagine this i mean so
yeah
i mean this is all learned stuff then i
started to get better
eventually oh this i was showing uh
slicing which was a front-end
development technique
way back a long time ago
so i i got you know quite a bit better
as
you know i kept practicing
all right so now let's keep on
uh now we're gonna switch gears and i'm
not gonna i'm gonna take
um doing reviews that i haven't seen yet
so
um let's go to twitter
and we're going to search for
live ui ux
review
latest uh you got a speeding ticket more
in ohio yep
so did i right so let's just check some
of these out i'm going to try to avoid
prototypes i want to do live websites
i'm going to move them off
all right so here's one
all right so okay
welcome to david's portfolio this page
is being tested on different devices
as of september 15 2020 you may continue
huge you access you don't do this nobody
cares
if you're you're testing it on different
devices like this is
this should be assumed so don't do that
let them go to your main user interface
and this is one of those things i where
someone in your shoes if you're the
person who created this or if you're
somebody creating things like this
definitely go back to the drawing board
when it comes to ui design
watch my my crash courses on my channel
i have ui ux design crash courses and
front end development crash courses as
well because there's just too many
things that are happening here for me to
sit here and
try to give this a comprehensive review
um
so yeah there's a lot of things that you
shouldn't be doing here
like the borders are over the place the
strong drop shadows
this is all just stuff that's very dated
and it's been quite a
you know the yeah the shadows everywhere
for some reason new ui designers they
get excited and in front of developers
and they want to use
all the cool effects but it's not it's a
hindrance try to keep things more
simple eye than not
so what for this one just because
there's there's so much that needs to be
improved we're not going to bother with
a rating
let's just move on to another one thank
you for the submission though
um let's see here we got a netlify app
one
now this to me looks like a a template
of design but again i don't like making
the assumption
that these are templates um
cosse all right
pretty solid here but you know when you
get out to these large
one second here when you get out to
these larger
uh resolution like this is 4k right here
um it just seems like it's a little bit
too stretched out like it might make
sense to take this
nav net this nav bar here and create and
make it into a a fixed centered
container kind of like how
this is right here outside of that it's
simple
i mean it's ultra simple
i like the little um this type of uh
gallery right here like the masonry
gallery style this is all pretty
pretty decent looking i don't really
have an issue with this
yeah this is a great example of a really
simple
design that i it works well though has
all the ui design fundamentals there
we have good contrast we have good white
space
we have good alignment for the most part
uh good visual hierarchy so i can't
really say anything too wrong
uh this right here though that's you
need more line height for sure
on that i probably want to use
a better ad copy for this a spring sale
of 30
that doesn't i would put that as like a
subtitle but then use something
that's completely different above that
so one being the worst timing the best
what do you people think this person
should get
for a rating
i already know what i'm going to rate it
yeah for me i'm going to give this a
let's see here
7.8 or so
yeah i think that's fair i mean again
when i say 7.8 you know this could be
depending on when you ask me like we
could have
like a three-tenths variation one way or
the other
let's check out some more
360 magnet solution
so i'm always moving these off just to
make sure
that there are designs that i can
present
all right okay i was getting i was
getting a little bit worried because i i
was
i was we're like almost 50 minutes into
this i think
yeah 47 minutes um and we didn't have
any of these uh
the whole crazy vector
animated designs occurring all right so
the first
issue with this design is
this image right here for one it's
pixelated it's a photograph so you
should
never use type baked into photographs
like jpegs or pngs or whatever
this is meant to be red easily and
it's just not working here so if you're
gonna use a photograph make sure it's of
like
non-typography things second
the type is just really large and it's
suffering from a lack of white space
and it's really spread out so i would
just if you're going to use this
this uh design right here or this
photograph rather
get rid of the type in the image leave
this white background here and then just
use html to put the
the images on top um
baking the type into the image
or the photograph that's something that
we used to do back during the slicing
days
sometimes you don't want to do that now
outside of that
this right here the animations
completely unnecessary
they're distracting so i remove that
even though it's cool
it's just not it it serves no purpose
outside of here the next section
yeah you're having issues with alignment
because the bottom of this
it's wrapping around this image but
really this whole
left portion should be maintained i
because it's just throwing off the flow
of the type you also have quite a bit of
type here i'm not sure if everybody
or most people will want to read through
all this so you might benefit by
reducing the amount of type here also
the type is a little bit screwed up
because you have you have this larger
this this one this right here is fine
but then you have a smaller type
as a sub headline not enough white space
but then you have slightly larger type
here so
things are thrown off like the size of
this type should be the size
uh of this type or vice versa um
and you need more white space like let
me show you how easily i could just
improve this area in a second so like
margin bottom
okay that's not working
oh it's oh there we go all right margin
bottom
all right so we've moved moved things
away just a little bit
and then we also have
this element margin top
oh what is happening here there we go
margin top there
so i fixed the white space issues at
least with this part
but again we have those other issues
here that need to be addressed
um digital agency services this part's
not not too bad actually
i've never really been a fan of having
embedded youtube videos just because
they kind of uh
it's hard to make them look good
especially like depending on what the
thumbnail looks like and also
the default ui design for the embedded
controls
so you might want to just have a button
here that just launches into it
perhaps or you can actually i think with
the youtube
player api you can have your own custom
splash image and then when people click
on it then it will it'll play right
inside of their
um their ui design
all right so what do you think this
person should get for a rating
by far i mean this stuff is better this
page or this sections
these sections right here are better
than what's happening up here the
biggest issue is this background
you have to fix that one being the worst
10 being the best let me know which
you all think
let's see if it's responsive
it is so that's working out at least
now i'm going to go ahead and give this
one a
4.5 or so
seems like most of you are rating it a
little bit higher
all right let's check out uh let's see
how long we've been doing this about
eight minutes we probably do
um one or two more um so let's continue
on
um
simple website made for learning
purposes
all right uh let's see here
yeah it is definitely on the simple side
um and that's okay i usually it's better
than trying to make things complex
because we see what that does
okay what's interesting is if you go to
my youtube channel
i just did a video
about full screen navigations
and i did link a video because it was
supposed to be included in this one
about the ui in the ux of full screen
navigations
so if you come to this url definitely
check this out
because i talk about this sort of thing
right here
this here don't do that
on desktop i because uh there's a few
reasons why
the main the the primary reason is when
you have this hamburger on desktop
you're requiring a user to click to
access links that would otherwise
already fit
right here so that's just it's a bad
pattern to use of course if we're
talking about
mobile design you don't have all that
physical room to place these links you
can do this
all right but not when you get out to
around here and you have enough space
so use and adjust your media queries
accordingly
outside of that um
it's a little bit it's a little bit
boring i would say for this this
particular illustration
um you might want to try to either get a
custom one or a rethink or get a
different one
um
i'm not a fan of see i would rather have
your your call to action
because it's really important that it
sticks out be styled like the hover
state rather than the default state
right here
the borders just kind of add a little
bit more complexity
this makes it more simple but it also
stands out more too
so i would change that and if you have
all this empty space here
you could probably restructure things a
little bit more to where
this type is larger
so we can bump that up to like twice the
size no not not twice the size
like 6.5 rem units possibly
now that's looking a little bit better
it's filling things out this
then can become larger as well not
the same size or anywhere near the same
size as this but it can still be
larger and then you'll fill out this
area a bit more
here we are i push this stuff down just
a tad bit more more white space beneath
this
it's a little bit too close to this text
area
and also when it comes to these
photographs or these illustrations
you know one way to do it is way you're
doing it just put it right there and
slap it there but you can also
um use it as a background image and make
them real large and kind of like
offs off it's hard for me to explain but
um you can have it so that these are
enlarged a lot larger
and they can even be cut off to the half
of the screen and then coming in
naturally
it kind of it's a more unique approach
um in a more appealing visually
appealing approach in my opinion
this part looks pretty decent make this
bold and maybe a little bit larger
more white space between this section
and that right here
but overall it's pretty good
i'll probably get rid of the thin
borders around these areas you don't
need those
all right so what do you people think
this person should get for a rating one
being the worst in 10 being the best
i'm going to refresh to see just to show
you what it originally looked like
and we can see there was definitely an
improvement by making that larger
it is responsive
um i'm gonna go ahead and give this one
like a
yeah probably like a
6.4 or so 6.5
all right thank you for that submission
um
we've been streaming for 57 minutes
apparently so
i'm gonna go ahead and give this uh
probably we'll do one more
one more review let's go ahead and i'll
refresh
all right starved collection
one second i'm checking it out
all right
so first let's refresh it so you can see
what you
experience on load
so by default we have a
we have a um a an embedded youtube
player that's starting automatically
probably wouldn't do that we could see
the um
at least it is muted by default but
there's more there's more interesting
ways you can go about
doing something like this you could take
this video clip and then
um you can make it as a part of like a
hero section like a watermark or
whatever
because again you're not it's being
muted anyway
um and then also continue to cite
huge ux no we don't do that anymore the
whole splash page thing
um you want to bring them to your site
by default already the main site with
your user interface
so if i click on continue to cite this
is what we are presented with which
unfortunately there's not much semblance
of a user interface here it just looks
like we have
a navigation up top the logo over here
and then we have just kind of like a
random
band graphic over here with tour dates
um so i think there needs to be more of
a restructuring
you know music sites are fun because
they're really
unique uh and they're creative and so i
would
maybe i'll even do a video about maybe
just compiling some of the most unique
or interesting
effective and non-effective banned
websites because they like like i said
by nature
they're usually really cool looking and
they're very different they're able to
do different things
because they're based on a creative
industry um
but i would like to see like for
instance
the navigation kind of seems more of an
afterthought
in this context and we have photographs
overlapping each other
um and so there's not a strong semblance
of a ui here
um like merchandise
what happens when i click this probably
just scrolls there okay yeah it does
and if you're gonna have a merch section
usually people want to know how much it
costs
so including that makes sense and maybe
scaling down the size of these and
putting them in
into actual card containers might make
sense as well
then again um like your music uh label
and and these two things right here they
could be left aligned
so having them on top you know it makes
more sense to put those in two columns
rather than just putting one after the
other
all right uh what do you think this
person should get for a rating one being
the worst and
10 being the best remem remember
we have this initial page which is a big
problem
with the uh the whole splash page and
requiring people to click here
completely just send them right to this
page instead
but again this has a number of issues
that
need to be addressed here as well
for me i'm just going to go ahead and
give this is it responsive i wonder
yeah it is i'm going to go ahead and
give this
a
4.5 or so i think that's
pretty fair it seems like most of you
agree with me anyhow
all right so that here is it
so that was the final stream of
the three-part stream series that we've
set up with uh free code camp here
of course i do this on my own channel uh
my own channel is
available at youtube.com forward slash
design course
um i do these like these see here's one
i did just four days ago
it's the same thing live ui ux review i
call it the negative space which is just
a play on
um ui design fundamental i'm not very
that much negative but it's the same
exact show that you saw here so if you
enjoyed these
subscribe to my youtube channel and i do
them usually once a week sometimes
uh once every two weeks and just do the
same exact thing
also we're working hard uh me and my
team
on getting designcourse.com ready
it's going to be months out from now but
if you want to be emailed in order to
take
uh become a member of this service where
we're going to have ui tests live
workshops challenges and full courses
yeah go ahead and just enter your email
to be notified when that releases
so i want to thank quincy larson for
having me
on i'm definitely interested in doing
this again sometime down the road in the
future
and yeah this was fun hopefully all
learned something here
as a part of this check out the other
two
uh live streams i did here in the prior
two weeks if you're more interested in
learning
as well i will see all of you sometime
in the future all right
goodbye